talk about the game sports continuing
coverage of the penny arcade expo 2014
I'm delighted to be joined by mr.
Timothy Schaeffer hello a little bit my
friend no sir yeah how are you doing
that's a great wave is I do like the
Queen I'm like walking the streets of
Seattle yeah the wrist ago that store
it's about there they got there for
about four we don't have one yeah I know
it's a killer they've also got one in
the expo hall as well apparently all
they're really cool stuff is here so I
heard the name I thought it was
something dirty but already pink gorilla
mmhmm yeah we all know what that means
yeah a double fine you guys are like
working on a thousand games at the momen
what's going on over there we have 1000
games ago we have a costume quest to you
were showing there and that Brad was his
name red mere bache he had something
come we're letting him do not search
alice is there and getting a lot of
people lining up to play that and we're
showing one of our double time presents
games just gang beasts yes which is have
you seen that I've played it we played
it on a panel yesterday in fact you'd
like adorably violent get drunk baby's
punching the hello each other it was it
true that that was supposed to be
placeholder ours but they decided to
keep it I I thought I heard that they
were had other plans to do i think i
remember seeing it and feeling like this
is this is perfect yeah stop like just
just to stop and and because i think
some of the things you do in the in the
game are just so much more effective
because you've got this kind of yeah
dead-eyed baby made a bug amorphous blob
yeah they blink now and they have these
costumes which make it even creepier all
I haven't seen the costume it is it this
way that one early access yesterday
right yeah yeah it's on out you can you
bind playing now yeah this actions make
it feel like that the movie to strangers
even more too
people are saying this is the future of
eSports yeah the chicken costumes yeah
yes this video game in general how did
that come about how did you guys pick
this one up cuz it was getting a bunch
of boys I know the Giant Bomb guys were
playing a lot of it giving a lot of sort
of exposure as well come along we've
been starting doing double fine presents
which is just our way of taking some of
the exposure that we have and sharing it
with other Indies and getting games like
a skate co2 and help happening last life
with her Kickstarter and an also
mountain gave a rally and then I think
this might have do this come in Greg
through the mail or did you how'd you
find out about this one yeah there's you
have a we have an address in DS a double
fine people can mail in be like rinche
stood and so that's how we found out
about it and you just play this game
once you're like oh my god how do I play
this how do i make my whole life about
this game you all look at that it's you
also have I know the guys from hitbox
I've kind of like a space within your
studio as well yeah we have this like
open space for Indies just to come and
yeah we have an extra a couple of rooms
that I remember when I was starting out
one of the hardest things when you're
starting companies like just figuring
out logistics of like do I rent space
and like do I peg how do I you know get
make enough money to have a deposit for
as one of the things that just you
should need to worry about when you're
just rying to make a game so we have an
empty empty room they were just letting
a bunch of Indies crashing and make
games there and we get to watch them and
by them before they're done is the other
ideas steal their ideas for our big it's
a especially important in the place like
San Francisco where the the rent is for
any sort of space like that is so on
yeah they do pay us in blood okay that's
very important and so this is up on
early access I think it says it's $15
then from twenty i think for if you get
in on it now yeah and when it back to is
it like the full version of gandhi's
gonna gonna hit the shelves full
internet shelves next thanks summer yeah
you can play right now but don't cuz
we're at pax and also maybe you're
watching classic I don't know right
after costume quest to as well you guys
had a day last week we went over and got
a bunch of footage Ava's and this is the
i guess the third costume quest game
attack
and why did you return to this one you
guys what have one of the best things
about Double Fine is so that you kind of
don't you're not beholden to your eye
peas a lot of the time you kind of make
new ideas and well they just always yeah
I know it's not like I really hate
sequels but I always you know we have
ideas for other games we want to make
all the time and and this was just a
game that every year we think about
because Halloween every house and every
Halloween I get this weird urge to play
it and other people do too and then they
start mailing us like look I play this
every year can you guys make the new
content for it yeah cuz some people's
like you watch the Charlie Brown you
know great pumpkin special yeah and you
play costume quest every year and we
wanted to just give more content to them
and the people at midnight city were
like would get together and make this
happen and so yeah it's got new costumes
got a wizard the pterodactyl in the
clown a personal favorite of mine but he
heals people with laughter terrifying
and that's the most terrifying thing I
had ever happened to a lot of people how
does the story work in this because you
guys kind of wrapped up pretty good on
the other ones what's life you remember
grubman's a nice ended with them in a
sea of portals oh yes um sir you enter
one of them but yeah and this is a new
adventure involving time travel
involving a mysterious dentist who's
trying to get rid of Halloween forever
Oh ever all the weight itself is on the
line again yeah you managed to find the
one universal thing that people hate is
it except for my dentist I want to point
out that you shout out to Tim's dentists
yeah don't hurt my teeth um but uh but
it's got all things people loved about
cost us the kids and the humor plus new
costumes in a much deeper combat system
you know there's different details that
make a lot more choices for the player
when they're playing all the the
turn-based combat with these monsters
and you can you can speed around as as
anyone now as well exactly yes I think
you yeah everyone's got roller skates
appreciated it and when is it out
Halloween next Halloween yes I'll be
back for xmas definitely by Christmas
okay no holla p I think it's obviously
something we wanted to get out before
all that and not on Halloween but you
know earlier maybe that's the future of
video games like like music where you
just make your Christmas single and you
bank on it every year
I think I should make like a st.
Patrick's Day video game it's like labor
day video game if we we talk about stuff
like that Christmas quest oh yeah but
the costumes are such a big part of it
in Halloween when we first made this
game a lot of the suggestions were
godlike it's great but could you take
out halloween because that means you can
only people only buy it at Halloween so
where the thing is is that that we might
only by the Halloween but they'll buy it
every other hella quick so it's turned
out to be a great great thing for us
from the the new to the old one of the
sort of most sought-after HD re-release
Azure re-imaginings you guys are
bringing grim fandango back a pending a
remaster remastered Jessica you guys
have a panel for clock you have the main
theater they got both the Peters for
your Chan the original artist lead
artist and Peter McConnell the composer
for the soundtrack and the producer of
the new version matt is give you there
and so we're going to talk about the
whole game in the new game and what
we're gonna do to bring it back to life
yeah that must be cuz was it 1998 1998
my you spot game of the year give it
here there you go Yeah right yeah game
over the year I try to save my voice to
the panel yeah fairly and it was that a
long time in the make it like people I'm
asking a lot of time to go so you can
say no it's not a long time let me tell
you by 1988 I know you don't want a corn
break your video games it's amazing year
the foo fighters are very big and um
were they mighty eighth think they
already yeah yeah yeah yeah people been
asking for this for the longest time it
did still the thought of as you know
perhaps perhaps the best adventure game
ever made made us wonder people bring up
a lot and it's kind of a really hard
game I've completed a bunch of times and
like how do you think the 2014 audience
will sort of i don't know like engage
with that's because with the monkey
island state but in the tip system and
whatnot like how are you gonna make it
so that i mean i think even care of it
our main thing is about making taking
the original game in remastering and
making it look and sound as good as we
can make it better more modern higher
fidelity and then I think the main thing
we want to revamp make modern is the
controls to make them really easy
because some of the difficulty came from
the controls actually moving money
moving man around which I was really
good at yeah but um I think players are
used to a different kind of control
scheme now so we're doing that and
giving you the option to which way if
you want to play and are you going to
keep the sort of him turning his head
for objects that are interactive and all
that stuff and we do you change and how
much do you keep I keep that but you can
drive them around with your stick an
intuitive way you know kind of like I
mean I kind of turn it evolved in
psychonaut so similar like as his head
would turn a look at things so it's
familiar but but we're not changing the
hints are not changing the game making
it easier in any way or changing the
puzzles or anything like that I think
people are there's a lot more
communication among people when they get
stuck on these things yeah internet and
so I think there's definitely ways to
not get stuck and we had the internet in
1998 to do hence games by Harlem's being
the gate you know around our website
yeah yeah we're still around I'm just a
bear stick it in there ah that's it's so
depressing you guys have gone from
strength to strength though Double Fine
is now this behemoth of development is a
large area ll be there is yes very large
supervene yeah and what's that like I
guess it must be strange working on
something like grim specifically when
you had such a small like core group of
people to now be looking at yourselves
in this really healthy position because
there was a time there were the
adventure game sort of genre was on its
knees and you guys look like you could
possibly go down I think it's like I
mean I think adventure games in the old
system of weight things got made we're
only big companies made you know games
and they had to be worth it a huge
investment of money and and they could
only be invested in the face if every
single player yeah there was an old way
of financing games and nowadays when you
have things like crowdfunding or you
have just ways for fans of a special
kind of game like adventure games can
now organize and get together yeah like
with our Kickstarter for Brooke and age
and they can say no we do want this and
we can take the risk away from you by
all getting together in advance and and
backing this project so that's how you
know that's how broken age came came to
be and I think helped show that they're
people who still want to play adventure
games out there
yeah and with broken age you guys had
you know the the use of voice in law not
has changed a lot since Grimm like
that's one of it's sort of usps at the
time was that it was a voiced and the
fact that it was 3d as well those assets
being from 1998 like especially I guess
the music with that iconic Sandra I have
you guys have to like rerecord stuff
remaster stuff like as I'm assuming most
of the sort of the rushes of data sort
of disappeared into the ether a lot of
the stuff we're doing right now is what
i would call like digital archaeology
like we're going through all these bins
of of dat tapes and tapes and formats i
don't even remember but we unique find
some like scuzzy drives we had to find
scuzzy drives to like unload some of
these old archives but we can find as
much as we as we can we're trying to
find the original source material is not
compressed yeah because you know last
I've got compressed in order to be in
the original game so we're trying to
uncompress it so we can go back to the
originals to just make it look and sound
I don't because that was 90 so we have
been on a CD as well so it was quite a
lot of voice work that was compressed
answer fit on you know yeah voice um the
voice files were similar quality to what
people use now cuz we always used really
high high fidelity voices in those games
the earliest earliest games like the
disk based version of David tentacle if
you get like 8-bit voice and you could
hear it when they say s words a veces
ass let's get all nasty but the grim
stuff is pretty good cool yeah you have
no stranger to pax you've been rare book
times what is it about the show that you
like we're talking before you came on
and I bad like the sort of the vibe here
what how important is it like actually
meeting people who play your games &
like talking to yeah it's it's amazing
acts is amazing because everyone is just
really nice Hey look they are all here
hey guys are all these nice people for
nice you guys are attractive and really
loud no um but you know because you
we're gonna game you know you see the
people in your office you see people
from the press and then you interact
with fans that were backers in our case
sometimes through the internet
and and sometimes the internet is on a
good day really nice and sometimes the
internet is for really angry people who
make you feel like what am i doing this
for anyway but you come to pax and meet
people in person and you and you get
reminded that there's just tons and tons
of just really great fans who connect
with what you're doing and they want to
give back their enthusiasm to you which
then you give back into your next game
so it's a great exchange of just that
and a reminder of that relationship that
we don't make games just for ourselves
or we don't make games for an anonymous
group and we make games for these
specific these players who who love them
and want to give that back so it's just
huge love fest yeah i think the huge
love fest is that strange sure yeah Tim
Schafer huge look love fest the print
t-shirts have you seen much like double
fine or like Oh Lucas cause playing
around there's always at least one who's
got that big Mannie yeah at the panel
we're having a panel today at four
o'clock and i'm hoping they'll be at
least one man is ok i saw bella from
broken age yesterday and she looked
amazing [ __ ] the hair franz it was
beautiful and it has always funded
someone in the back her shirt over there
thanks for backing it's always fun and
the Double Fine presents tough and
obviously we talked about your space
that you have in the office as well like
that outreach to indie developers does
any of that happen this week because
like this is one of the few times of the
year where you know a lot of developers
are in the same space and I guess what's
on the like III you tend not to get that
sort of grassroots that development
community do you spend any time and like
the indie mega booth like alright
talking about we're very very close to
the new mega booth and I love checking
out the game's over there we're having
like we're actually invited other we
usually do like a fan meet up on sunday
night at the hard rock and this time
we're having other developers join us
there and so now we're calling it devs
and Bev's cool come on down to the hard
rock on Sunday night excellent and hang
out cuz we're having um other developers
show their games too hmm have you had a
walk around the Utley mega but
yourselves anything in particular that
you sort of i'm going there later okay
yeah i've been stuck in my booth talking
my my voice order to going signing some
things i signed a burrito yesterday you
signed a burrito yeah with a pen with a
pen did he or she eat it after i did not
see here Zi tweeted a picture of it cuz
uh well I didn't really sign it i drew i
noticed that ahead of burrito and put it
this way it looks exactly like Manny's
head
Miguel Rivera said so I'd romantic aloe
vera head on it great hopefully will
turn into one of those stories about a
miraculous face appearing on a tortilla
for breakfast I know I'm not somebody
going to the hospital because of ink
what gives it meaning ingat that'd be a
small dosage it's a small price to pay
for eating a beautiful piece of art
we've talked about every single thing
you're doing except for massive chalice
so let's talk a little bit top of that
it's on there and you're you foray into
the world of kick starting a mass
accessible first time with broken age
you guys have thought it here which with
Brad muirs magnum opus and how did this
sort of original idea come around this
looks great you know Brad we were
spending time pitching some various
concepts of games that brad had to
publishers and and we had different
levels of interests and we had one
publisher who wanted to do one of brad's
games ideas but we didn't really like
the the terms of the deal and it seemed
like you know really care about certain
things like controlling our intellectual
property yes I always think developers
[ __ ] on their properties you know well
especially with your priors at Lucas as
well i guessing with grim it wasn't an
easy situation is Ryan wrestle on but
yeah I mean luckily in that case there
are some sympathetic people at the
bigger companies I just want to see that
game made so that helped us get over
that hurdle but um with Brad's game we
just it was the first time we were like
had a publishing deal that we said no to
were like no we'd rather go to the fans
and say hey would you help us make this
game our way and and brad had this idea
is like i want to do this turn-based
strategy things kind of fantasy and way
you do this creepy breeding stuff and I
was like creepy breeding yeah I'm in
shaffer loves eugenics hi hi um well
have to have that explain later but I am
I that's the part of the game that I
actually find really really interesting
because it just taking over a long
period of time and really thinking about
the passage of time and then the enemies
being kind of time-based and and just
thinking about what you pass on to these
kids and
it's it's it that's that's my favorite
part of the game and what's it like now
having this studio which for the longest
time was associated with one genre like
I think when you guys I guess
psychonauts probably the one that sort
of broke you out of that in terms of a
lot of people's perceptions to this
where you're making you know a
turn-based strategy game now have action
platformers adventure games with did you
ever feel at any stage here in your
career that like any sort of negativity
around the people thinking you guys
weren't really go to make it adventure
games but we're not good at it would
know that your only grab look thought
that was your thing I mean it seems like
we always do something different every
time and I like that and I think the
thing that is consistent is that we are
in like an inspiration driven company so
there our process starts with like
having a great idea I have a great idea
for game not trying to think about like
take two games that are popular and you
know or but but but it's something I
want to make this game that I love like
and and and trusting people like Brad or
one of the creative people at our office
who want to make a game and if they
really believe in it and they're gonna
this is their baby like giving them a
chance to make it and doing it in a
creative way where we you know protect
creativity and really value that so I
think it's been consistent over all our
game so we always I think people know
hopefully by now that will Charlie's try
and do new things that we've never done
before yeah and it seemed to be doing
quite a lot of it at the moment yeah at
to shaver thank you so much for coming
james shay for everybody
you